are you gonna call I've tried a little
something different with the camera
setup we'll end up seeing how this looks
but in any case guys new Ghostbusters
movie is out and I'm not talking about
it yet what I am gonna talk about is
something that I've been putting off for
a while because I've been working my way
through the entirety of the Real
Ghostbusters cartoon I have the entire
box set every episode finally got
through it this is not an overview of
that series I do plan to do that at a
later date this is top 10 real
Ghostbusters episodes I've gone through
them there's some fantastic episodes
when this show was good it was great so
let's get right into it starting with
number 10
standing room only this is one of the
later episodes which just goes to prove
that even though many fans will say that
once it became slimmer and the Real
Ghostbusters as it went to heck not true
they did still get some good episodes
out during that time and this was one of
them there's sort of two stories going
on at once in this on the one hand
you've got Peter trying to create a
device that will actually attract the
ghosts to them so they don't have to go
out and hunt them all the time and then
at the same time you have the rise of
this huge ectoplasmic entity called
Mikra and what this thing does is it
feeds off of other ghosts which means
that by consolidating a whole bunch of
ghosts into one place like Peter's
trying to doing all these major do is
attract this huge monstrous destructive
force that they may not be able to stop
is one of the more straightforward and
kind of intense episode of the later
seasons and it stands out for that
reason Mikra I'm self has a cool design
on him we got all sorts of spooks
showing up in this one a lot of chance
for the character designers to show off
what they can do and it's one of the few
times that Peter gets highlighted as a
scientist which he so rarely is number 9
Janine's genie there are not a ton of
Jenin centric episodes overall I mean
she shows up and she's used differently
in the latter half of the show than she
is in the first half but this she's
pretty much front and
Center and this is a case where she is
tired of being behind the desk she goes
with the guys on the job and after they
do their busting she gets her hand on a
lamp and what claims to be a genie that
is granting her wishes but what it
actually is is the lamp is a gateway to
another dimension and just evil spirits
are pouring into the firehouse it really
gives Jeannine a chance to shine because
ultimately by the end of the episode you
realize she could go out on jobs and
stand up with these guys and do this
work but she kind of goes you know what
I had my fill I'm good and I like that I
like this sort of it's a bit empowering
because it's not saying she can't do the
job it's like I don't want to I'm good
where I am in addition to that a lot of
very cool
ghosts and creatures that we get in this
it's got some of the higher end
animation it's from the first sort of
block of episodes that they did from ABC
which had some of the better and more
amped-up quality animation so it looks
great there's some terrific gags that
happen on an airplane there's some good
jokes Janine is good it's a lot of fun
number eight the devil to pay now here's
a concept very of its time because the
cartoon was going on in the eighties
when this episode came out and it's
focused around game shows and game shows
were huge in the eighties I mean they're
still around now but it's not the same
and the idea and this one is that the
guys go on what they think is a standard
game show but it ends up being run by a
minor demon who is trying to get them to
lose their souls if they lose this game
now that sounds like it would be weird
and stupid and kind of goofy except that
they really emphasize how up the stakes
are in this and it's just played really
well the Vilna that they've gotten this
div Devlin he's just he really has that
smarmy nastain a great bad game show
host and watching the guys pull it
together work the problems as they come
up it's just it's a great progression
the dynamics between all the characters
are terrific and honestly I'm premise at
the time that it was airing the idea of
a character who even though they make it
clear if he is not the devil has a
devilish appearance and is trying to win
their souls that's kind of ballsy that
they that they went fair number seven
mrs. Rogers nay
hood now this is another one with some
really cool inventive stuff because the
show actually did not do flat-out
haunted-house all that often which is
what this one is
and when I say haunted house I don't
just mean house with ghosts in I mean
the house itself is kind of in on the
whole thing and it's messing with them
and the doors are doing weird things and
then there's the Ville in it I don't
want to spoil too much about it but it's
a demon called what and the design on
this thing is great as monstrous it's
got these this sort of beak thing but it
just looks like just these protruding
gums and teeth and and there's some
great creepy stuff that happens towards
the end when a character gets possessed
and like the show especially early on
was not afraid to get kind of scary the
way the movie got scary and this episode
does that very well number six Egon on
the rampage so this is another one
premise sounds goofy but they just they
just played it just right idea in this
one and actually the framing device that
kind of makes this cuz the premise
itself is it's fine it would have been a
good standard episode but it's it's
presented like a segment of a news
program where you've got these
newscasters who the jerk newscasters and
they bust their way into the into the
firehouse and they're demanding you know
we want to see what's going on in here
and it's framed like through that what
you're seeing is what they're
broadcasting so they get some good digs
in on sort of you know news media of the
time and some which is still
surprisingly relevant but they get some
cool jokes some cool digs in on that and
then the idea is that one of Iran's
equipment goes wrong and he ends up
possessed and he's like kind of Hulk's
out if you know this big monstrous
purple version of Egon just going crazy
and that's a fun enough idea in and of
itself but like I said the again between
that and the framing device of this of
this BS news cast that's going on it's
it son really nice marriage and the two
things work off of each other really
well number five the collect call of
cthulhu I you know what I'm so glad this
episode was as good as it was because on
tight
alone I'm like oh please be good cuz I
just love saying that the collect call
of cthulhu yeah they bring in V
Lovecraftian horror the big one and the
ghostbusters take him on and it's like
legit ii would like the cults
worshipping Cthulhu and all that and you
know Cthulhu looks great he's huge he's
monstrous he's in keeping with what
people tend to think of what they think
of Theo Lewin and he's treated with the
gravitas that you would want for
something like this he's not treated as
a one-off dagger like just the monster
that we like no no this is a big problem
so it's given the weight and that sort
of this could be the end of the world
thing and the funny thing is most of the
best episodes of the show tend to have
the high really raised stakes and this
one has that and it's Cthulhu in
ghostbusters how can you go wrong number
four knock-knock
another one that's really the stakes
make it basically there is a door in the
subway that if it gets open sets off
doomsday and it gets opened ahead of
schedule and the ghostbusters have to
deal with it and there's just sort of
this spillage of all these supernatural
things going on in the subway which
lends itself to some some funny little
gags and some cool visuals and then of
course like you said raised stakes high
stakes I think this show just does so
much better when it feels like
everything hangs in the balance and this
episode really has that in spades it's
honestly it's probably the episode that
did this could be the end of the world
better than any other now before I get
into my top three I'm gonna do some
honorable mentions because I was so
tempted to make this a top 15 because I
narrowed it down to 15 and then I'm like
oh I should it should really just be a
top 10 so here are the five that almost
made it but didn't quite flip side where
the Ghostbusters go to a basically
mirror universe of New York where humans
are the freaks and they are hunted by
the human busters dairy farm which
sounds boring as heck but honestly it's
got zombies in like legit look
decaying zombies in it you props the
boogeyman cometh
this one is actually really important in
terms of the backstory of the characters
it just didn't quite crack the top 10
for me in terms of visceral enjoyment
but it's the boogeyman it turns out that
the boogeyman used to terrify Egon and
that's why he even started investigating
the supernatural it's cool insight into
Egon it's a cool episode the other ones
that didn't quite make it we've got
killer watt which is is honestly just a
whole lot of fun you've got possessed
machinery which grizz's some great
visuals and then finally the last
honorable mention i want to give out is
Jeanine you've changed which is the
episode where they basically hang a
lampshade on the fact that they visually
redesigned Jeanine and recast her voice
and it's kind of cool that there's an in
continuity acknowledgement that not only
did it happen but somehow the characters
never noticed up to then and it's kind
of a cool way to deal with that but
getting back to the list proper I had
such a hard time ordering these top
three as is usually the case when I do a
top 10 I would bet money if I did this
again I might switch these three around
but this is the order I landed in for
right now number three citizen ghost
this is the story of why Slimer is their
friend even though he was not in the
original movie i don't know how
well-known this episode is but it's
actually he's a really cool explanation
of how we got from he was the creepy
little spud who slimed peter in the
hotel - he's basically their pet so it
deals with Slimers integration into the
ghostbusters and it's got some cool
things that they have to deal with
anyway with these sort of spectral
doppelgangers
sort of ethereal and creepy instead it's
great agonist and it's a cool background
on Slimer and how we got to what the
status quo of the show is comment up so
close to the top number two when
halloween was forever Samhain the spirit
of Halloween one of the only recurring
villains on this show and there is a
good reason he is awesome
he's spooky he's creepy he's got a great
voice
he's visually just iconic as heck and
again wonderful variety of creatures in
this the designers got to go nuts on
this one and it just looks great and
some genuinely scary designs on some of
these things - this is
show you would expect a killer halloween
episode on and this delivers like you
would not believe it still stands as one
of my favorite Halloween's just specials
episodes whatever of all time certainly
probably my favorite anime yes I will
put this up against it's the Great
Pumpkin Charlie Brown I know that blast
me for some but I mean it it does not
quite make my number one though because
my number one had one of my favorite
villains who initiated some of my
favorite scenarios again the designers
got to go nuts and just give us so many
awesome visuals stuff it's got the high
end visuals that you got from the early
ABC episodes and that is mr. Sandman
dream me a dream what a random odd idea
The Sandman who helps people go to sleep
with magic dust suddenly decides you
know what humanity should just go to
sleep for about five hundred years and
just dream and when they wake up maybe
they'll be better maybe they'll be nicer
maybe there won't be so much Wars and
Fighting's that they just live in their
dreams for around five centuries or so
and the voice on the same his design is
so simple but they get some really great
creepy looks out of it and I love the
voice that voice is this is this weird
understated yeah it's like it's not
quite old man voice it's not quite like
this Auto to thing it's just it's a
weird voice and it's wonderfully creepy
and I love that he's like he tries to be
all calm but when he gets angry and you
know what he turns the dreams into
nightmares and there's these walking
dreams all around in these crazy bizarre
stuff that allows not only for great
creatures and great monster designs but
just great random gags because some
people have weird random dreams so
there's weird random dreams running
around this is my favorite episode
of one of my favorite cartoons but it
didn't have to be yours so what is your
favorite episode whatever it is or you
just want to slag me off because you
think my list was crap drop something
down in the comments let's talk about it
don't forget to Like subscribe check me
out on Twitter at council of geeks give
a listen to the council of geeks podcast
on itunes and stitcher and until next
time this council is adjourned